alright so thank you so much for braving
the weather which is getting I guess
more
like by the minute I'm hoping we don't
float away in the auditorium halfway
through the talk but we're really
delighted to have Professor Jonathan
Butterworth with us tonight I first want
to say a word about this series that
that it's a part of so it's part of the
showman's seminars and lectures and
Sciences and science and the humanities
this is the first one of this semester
inaugurated in spring 2007 the showman
seminars and lectures and science and
the humanities aim to encourage
sustained dialogue and intellectual
collaboration across the proverbial
divide between the two cultures the
series represents a bold and exciting
convergence of the Arts and Sciences and
so is fittingly named after Robert
Schulman why believe is here sterling
professor emeritus of chemistry
molecular biophysics and biochemistry
senior research scientist in diagnostic
radiology and the founding fellow of the
whitney an unwavering supporter of the
integration of science and the
humanities Bob Schulman truly and fully
embodies the spirit of this program and
Emily coats and I hukou teach the
physics and dance class that's happening
this year as a showman lecture class are
certainly thrilled to be associated with
this so thank you so much for this
opportunity the series is supported with
the generosity of Richard and Barbara
Frankie so now on to Professor
Butterworth John is the chair of the
physics and astronomy department at
University College London he grew up in
Manchester he went to Oxford for his
bachelor's degree and his doctorate in
physics after doing that doctorate in
physics he went to work to work on the
Zeus experiment or actually maybe even
started during the doctorate he worked
on the Zeus experiment which is an
experiment of about 450 people quite a
few people it's at the Hera electron
proton Collider at Daisy which is an
international lab that's in hamburg in
Germany he worked there first as a
postdoctoral research scientist and
actually he was working officially for
Pennsylvania State University and you
can read in the fantastic book that he
wrote that I'll mention soon
about some of his early trips to the US
and what was that was like as a young
physicist coming over here to work for
an institution but actually he based at
an international lab in Germany it's not
an uncommon thing in our field so he he
worked with Pennsylvania State
University and then joined UCL as
faculty he was able at this electron
proton Collider to probe the content of
the proton and he's credited with the
first measurement of the photo
production of hadronic jets he moved to
Atlas in around 2006-2007 and one of the
initial things that he did that was
incredibly helpful for the Atlas
experiment was take the data that we had
from Zeus about these hydronic jets and
apply them to the Hadron Collider where
basically most of what we have is jets
so we're all very grateful for that that
transitional work we learned a lot about
the proton itself and the different
constituents of the proton and how much
energy they carry when the proton is
traveling at different speeds so this is
an excellent way that different
experiments actually piggyback on each
other these large experiments deuces 450
Atlas is about three thousand they have
a lot of internal structure and John has
had a lot of leadership positions inside
of these experiments as he's gone on he
was the physics chair within Zeus from
2003 and 2004 which is really overseeing
the physics program which is an
excellent way to get an overview of many
hundreds of analyses that are ongoing
and then when he came to Atlas he
started out with the Atlas Monte Carlo
group convening that from 2007-2009
that's looking at our simulation across
the experiment and then became the
convener of the standard model group
from 2010 to 2012 he was the convener of
that group when my group was working on
a standard model analyses so we had a
little bit of interaction through that
he also has done some work at the the
borders between experiment and theory so
John received the Chadwick prize from
the Institute of Physics in 2013 for
some of this pioneering work he wrote
what we call that what he called the
Jimmy program and he defends that name
though doesn't really tell you what it
means in the book which is
doesn't leave anything right doesn't
mean anything okay but it actually
stimulates multi-part on collisions
which is incredibly important and we
used it very heavily in run one of Atlas
when it was turned on John has a science
blog a lot of people have science blogs
but John happens to be hosted by the
Guardian newspaper so he has a large
readership for his blog and as I
mentioned he wrote a book most wanted
particle about the Higgs discovery it's
a fantastic book that's personal it's
humble and it's jam-packed with
accessible physics so I highly recommend
it we asked John to be part of this
lecture series because of the many
things that he's done he's an
accomplished researcher in particle
physics a collaborator of mine on Atlas
who had had some interactions with and
also because of his interest in outreach
in science and he thought deeply about
the process of research and throughout
this lecture series where we have
physicists coming and also dance artists
and choreographers coming we've really
asked them to talk to us about what is
the process of discovery in your field
what does it look like and what you do
it's something we're examining in the
class so thank you very much for coming
again braving the weather and please
help me welcome yes sir Jonathan
butterworth
thank you very much so this is a real
pleasure and an honor to be is the first
time i've been to yale and it's the
first time I've actually given a
dedicated interdisciplinary lecture
between the arts and humanities as well
i think is a fantastic case yes to do
thank you very much even and that even
includes the fact that i attended the
physics and dance class early it's a day
which which was also very interesting
and a lot of fun sigh thank you for that
yes so this is obviously this is
subliminal advertising for the book in
the background but the cycle is research
with the energy frontier what why and
how that's obviously quite a lot to get
through in 45 minutes and i'm really
going to give you a flavor of it but i
hope there will be a few things that
you'll you'll learn and remember from
this some of them about physics a sort
of them maybe about how science
interacts with the public and by the
media so yes so this is this is where it
all happens this is where a Sarah and I
do I science now this is the view that I
got from the airplane window if I was
lucky about twice a week well the Large
Hadron Collider was starting up what
you're looking at here is this is how
you're flying over the Jura mountains
which are in the kind of the east of
France swords aside this is mont blanc
on which is the highest peak in the alps
on the horizon and this is like Geneva
here and this will be Geneva Airport
where I would be either leaving or
arriving at the bit you won't see of
course because the French farmers would
have objected if we tried to paint it
but this is this is the path of the
Large Hadron Collider is marking that
the path of a tunnel underground which
is 27 kilometers around and inside that
tunnel we have the highest energy
particle beams that humanity's ever
managed to sustain and create some focus
and actually they're good to them going
in opposite directions and we bring them
into head-on collision four points on
that ring and I guess that silently
physics of some level and thus this is
the energy frontier now
and everyone I'm going to tell you
something about the kind of sociology on
the physics of what went on there the
four points that the beams are collect
collide out no marks here is one of them
here LHCb atlas this is the main certain
lab here and you can see some of the
previous high-energy machines in the
world which are now boosters discern of
this blue ring here for instance and
then alleys and CMS over here i'm going
to show you data from these two atlas
and CMS surface is the one that Sarah
and I work on the other two are doing
more specialist measurements which are
great physics and I recommend it but I'm
not going to say any more about it here
there's a lot you can do when you have
these beams but what Atlas and CMS are
doing is really exploring this energy
frontier and in particular the Nobel
prize-winning result that we got so far
although the prize went to the theories
but nevermind it was for the discovery
of the Higgs boson so I'll talk a little
bit about that as a fairly well-known
example of what a nother I'll try will
give you an example of what really
happened so one of the features of this
is that it did feature in the news media
and in the general consciousness I think
here in the US this is the second talk
i've given i gave a talk in the library
in chicago and a lot of people seem to
have heard something of this and
certainly in the UK had a bigger impact
than then many science stories ever do
which in some ways surprising because
actually this would really make any
difference to people's lives whether we
find the Higgs or not well people seem
to actually care about it but one of the
frustrating things about science in the
media is you get a kind of 23 minute pop
up on some news channel and you
basically all you got time to do is say
Eureka and there's no build-up there's
no consequences there's there's also the
right of the rest of physics for the
past 200 years is probably news to the
person interviewing you answer a big
fraction of the audience so it's really
difficult to you always get the news is
always right on the frontier so it's
always a stuff actually you probably
don't know we've might be gravitational
waves the neutrinos are probably not
traveling faster than speed of light but
those are the things that people would
like to know about and we may have found
expose I know we may not yet kind of
thing you'll see that we have now but
what this is while it was being
developed
so it's always good to try and connect
it back to basic physics and actually
today I'm even going to try and connect
it back to the dance class because
there's one question you can you can
answer which is why is it so big well if
I work in London now London reasonable
amount of money in London why do I have
to go to inserted into Geneva to do my
work why don't we have one that you see
out oh why does Sarah have to go all the
way to Europe to do this and the reason
for that is because it's very big which
means it costs a lot of money and it's
very hard to build so it makes sense to
pool resources and only have one but
then why is it so big and the answer it
the reason it's so big is actually
Newton's third law which was mentioned
today these are the highest energy beams
of particles we've ever had they wants
to go in a straight line at constant
speed more than any other particle we've
ever had that's what will happen two
particles if you've ever seen if you see
in gravity the movie for instance they
get some of that wrong to be honest but
things in space would just keep moving
the reason they we don't if we throw a
ball he doesn't go in a straight line
forever because of gravity acting on it
and because it in the end what if there
was no gravity than wind resistance was
slowing down nevertheless without those
forces it would keep moving so and we
were studying friction in the dance
class today if I started sliding I would
just never stopped if it wasn't for
friction I would carry on going in a
straight line bodies will do that that's
Newton's law so these particles wants to
go in a straight line more than any
other particle we've ever had in a lab
that's what it means to say that the
highest energy beams the highest
momentum beings we have so the thing
that sets the limit is can you persuade
them to go around a corner it's not how
much energy can you pump into the beam
actually it's can you persuade them to
go around the corner and come back again
and actually hits each other and be
stored in in the ring and the things
that set that limit then are two things
how strong is that the force you can
exert to make them bend around the
corner and how sharp is the corner this
is why on a free wave of the corners are
narrow the corners are very gentle and a
right angle corner on a road you have to
slow down especially in this weather to
go down play this is where friction
comes in right so the thing that turns
you turns your car around the corner is
friction between the wheels and the road
and that's that's the force that acts
and will bring
car around the corner and you feel you
feel yourself being thrown out at the
corner but the friction will keep you on
the road unless you go too fast and in
the end the thing that limits how fast
the car can go around the corner is the
friction the maximum force that can be
exerted and the sharpness of the corner
and it's exactly the same with the LHC
so we it's not friction doing it it's a
magnetic field that provides the bending
force so we build the most powerful
magnets that we can build we know how to
build the bender beans and then the
thing that sets the limit on the energy
is how sharp is the corner if you want a
very gentle curve unfortunately you need
a very big ring so 27 kilometers is done
so it's an optimization between the
geology of Geneva and can you dig a
tunnel the expense will the taxpayers
fund it and and then how powerful the
magnets can you build and then that
sells you have high energy to be moving
so that's the car so you know that if
the beams kids off the road that's very
bad news so we don't do that so I'll say
a little bit more about the organization
that build this this is these are the
member states of CERN as of now the blue
the ones colored in blue this is the
latest ones who join with Israel which
is that down in the corner here and it
was set up in 1954 just over 60 years
ago to try and help rebuild basic
European science after the disasters of
the Second World War and of course one
of the disasters in the second world war
with it practically every physicist was
in America agenda Danell came over here
so so there was a way to try and build
up collaborate collaboration across the
borders and basic science again the UK
despite the UK's grumpy attitude to
Europe it was actually in this from the
beginning of the state in it ever since
it was one of the last things Winston
Churchill did in his final term as Prime
Minister was to sign the deeds who said
ok can be in Geneva we don't mind and
we've been in it since little very
diversified service and it's been a kind
of fed at the level of about a billion
currency units swiss francs dollars
something like that a year pretty
constantly for the last couple of
decades which is a lot of money but adds
up but it's it's spread out over all you
taxpayers and and the great thing is
that is cumulative you saw that on the
map I showed you the old machines are
actually now that the injector stages of
the new machines and that kind of build
up the technology and expertise there
has really helped so to the extent now
that everywhere that okay Africa was
supposed to be great but everywhere that
you can see on here is have some
collaborative arrangement with ranging
from formal observer status or applying
to join or down to descending some PhD
students exchanging students with the
certain things so it's now really to
place the world comes to energy frontier
physics the blue ones are still member
states it is a member state inside
America here but it's actually France
it's French Guiana swear they launched
the Aryan rockets from so okay so that's
the organization this is the experiment
so I on the ring I said the beams are
brought into collision and foot in four
places and two of them are Atlas and CMS
which is where i'm going to i'm going to
talk about the data from that this is a
picture of the Atlas detector so you've
got to imagine one of the beams coming
in that way one of the rooms going that
way they cross in the middle here and
some of the particles collide they're on
the game is to record what happens in
those collisions as accurately as
possible and as quickly as possible and
try and work out what was going on in
the hearts of the collision from that so
you can see there are sort of concentric
cylinders different technologies telling
those different things about about these
about particles they tell us you know
how how fast they were traveling what
their energy was sometimes what kind of
particle they were I'm not going to say
any much anymore about this now others a
lot one could say we said some point out
it's quite big these are these are
people here if you hadn't spied them so
it's a huge piece of the apparatus
bigger than CMS although not as having
apparently so everyone has a superlative
in particle physics or CMS of the
heaviest Latina women where the biggest
and detect this is a this is a picture
of it that some of you I said just
there's anyone seen this picture before
one or two Nadu yeah so it's it's one of
the it really is from 2005 actually
while we were building the artist
so this is one of the people building it
and it really I give talks in classrooms
and various other places and very often
in England this would be on the wall in
the classroom and just in a general
science class to infer kind of 13 year
old children just because somehow it
caught people's imagination my dad is
actually a priest and this even turned
up in the church times which is kind of
his work Mac it really had a kind of
depth of penetration in the I didn't
expect my physics experiment to do when
I just became a physicist and I think
that was a sign that people were
generally interested in it this was in
2005 we were we were trying to engage
people and actually when when we
switched on the beam for the first time
we had we had journalists in the control
room which was unheard of I mean people
really didn't want the standard thing in
science is to do all the difficult stuff
and then emerge triumphant me shouting
Eureka and show everyone how clever you
are we didn't do that we actually had
people in there well we started the
Machine up and in the book I describe
how tennis that was at the time it was
it was really really interesting to be
on live TV and actually be still be more
nervous about your experiment starting
done you were about being on light
either you know you've never done it
before and it was a lot of fun people it
was very positive people were really
interested but I think the this
importance point out that it wasn't all
fun and it's often you get people being
you can see I'm not really having fun
but the people when you when you decide
you make a big decision when you decide
to do science and public or not I need
and it's all kind of a robot irrevocable
decision so you have to if he's going to
tell people how great your experiment is
you have to be prepared to some of them
will say that's not very great you're
going to destroy the world which is what
this guy thought we were going to do
this isn't when we were switching on
these beams so as the people were one or
two essentially eccentric or or actually
bad evil people who were out not evil
but you know attention seekers who were
trying to scare people I could never
make my mind up whether they were
actually deluded or or cynical about
what they were doing but it was very
powerful whatever I know as I was in
Geneva just before
we were in the build-up to switching on
and I got a call from Al Jazeera whoever
based in England I'd have an English
base in an Arabic waist and they're
based in london and had done some things
with them before they call me up said
can you come into the studio and talk
and do an interview with us because the
guy from CERN has just cancelled now I
should have thought why did the guy from
Sarah council we're in Geneva why are
they calling me yeah but anyway I said
sure and I went along and it was this
guy who's a guy called also from tubing
a German guy who was a theoretical
biochemist although I don't think that
really means anything he was the one
scientist in Europe who was convinced
that we were going to destroy the
universe when we turned on the machine
so I would when I put I wasn't actually
in front of the lake I was in a dark
room under an industrial estate
somewhere on the outskirts of Geneva
with a thing in my ear and a bright
light in my face and no no view of
anything else and I wasn't very happy
about this and it was terrifying because
it also it wasn't life and you might
think that live would be scarier but
it's not it's really scary when you
because if it's not lie during the mercy
of the editor if you say nine sensible
things and one silly thing they confuse
just to show this everything I was very
worried about it actually anyway I did
the interview had no choice then and
when I saw it in the end I was really I
really learned a lesson I think about
once you started talking simply for the
public about your experiment first of
all the the the editor did a good job
you get a fair impression of the
interviewer and it was pretty obvious it
was only one mad scientist in the room
and it wasn't me but the the other thing
is al Jazeera really has a different
reach from the BBC and there were people
in the developing world that they reach
who were actually genuinely scared about
what was going on in Geneva and this the
feedback they got from this was so
overwhelmingly positive they were kind
of stunned so it's I think you really
you've gotta realize it's very
frightening for scientist because you
lose control once you once you go to the
public and you after I set that because
if you if you've brought invited the
media in and then you try and control
them then the backlash will be huge you
just have to invite them in and be
honest and that's really what we try to
do and we even did that when
blue orb which was pretty bad as well
nine days after we switched it on we had
a catastrophic helium leak and we
destroyed it but ain't with it
practically set us back by 18 months it
was a dreadful time especially the PhD
students who were just starting at that
point but that's what happens when you
do research and in the in the grand
scheme of things he really showed that
the thing hadn't been stage-managed that
we really were showing people are really
then notnot some kind of satan's
attention you know we were actually
terrified and elated when it did work
and then devastated when it didn't and
then we came back and 8c months later
and it did work so it gave a much truer
impression of what research is really
like as well and it would have been
awful if we'd have all just retreated
into our shells again after when it went
wrong but we didn't we even put up with
people come and get the god particle and
all kinds of ridiculous stuff so that's
the kind of detour into the the the the
experience of doing science in in the
glare of media spotlight if you like
which was very not something we expected
them not something we're really prepared
to deal with but I think overall was a
very positive experience we go back to
the science now so this is a this is a
view of one of the collisions of those
two of a pair of protons in these two
beings that we're bringing into
collision many many times a second and
you three three angles three
representations of the same collision so
that this is a slice through the
cylinder obviously so you see the
circular thing you've got to imagine one
of the beams coming from the back of the
whole the other one coming from behind
the screen and they collide in the plane
of the screen and you see that is the
this gray the gray stuff here is kind of
not very interesting low energy stuff in
fact you can tell it's low energy
because it's being bent by the magnetic
field we have on here and the force back
to the car going around the corner the
force is enough to bend the particles so
they're not very high momentum whereas
these two guys the yellow ones are very
high momentum chris has hardly been bent
at all by the magnetic field also by the
fact that they punched through all the
different layers of detector we can tell
that they're muons which is something
I'll come back to in a moment but that's
a heavy version of the electron so it's
often there are many many ones around in
nature so it's often a sign that
something interesting happened
now if you look at this projection this
is your to slice through the cylinder
same collision but with the beams going
this way and this way now and that red
dot and you zoom in on the red dot this
is what you would see and you see that
these parcels an ultimate from the same
place each one of those little ellipses
is a source of particles that are flying
out and that have been detected in the
in the in the Alice detector and there
are several of them they're about 12 of
them here in fact what that means is
that the protons are not coming one at a
time and they're not coming continuously
that they come in bunches so come in
every 25 nanoseconds we get a bunch of
protons and nano second is a billionth
of a second so every type of 25
nanoseconds we got a bunch of packed
with protons as many problems as we
possibly can into the bunch and a few
mode they're very small boats on the
most of them miss each other completely
and go around and have another go but
but some of them will collide and in
this case about 12 pairs of photons
collided actually whether the way we
were running at the end of the year is
more like 60 or so or even more house in
pilot was about 60 on average yeah it's
a lot but we went to short a bunch
spacing so yes so it's a lot going on in
there and in fact we owe were only
interested in the ones that produced
here so all the rest is noise as far as
we're concerned this and we want to get
rid of it so you have to pick that out
and as a physicist I'm not very good at
remembering numbers but what I do
remember is a speed of light which is
three times ten to the eighth meters per
second which is actually about 30
centimeters about a foot per nanosecond
okay now the fastest these particles are
traveling is the speed of light some of
them they're all that or below so they
don't have time if you think about it to
get out of that huge detective in Texas
15 inches long and then you have to get
your signals down the wire and that can
only go to the speed of light as well so
these are coming every 25 nanoseconds we
have another spray of particles and
another and another most of which we
don't want anyway we just want these
guys and so that kind of data processing
challenge is absolutely huge keeping
them all in time so you know which ones
belong in the same time window is each
other joining the dots to make the
tracks deciding whether you want to keep
this event or throw it away and which
ones you want to focus on because you
can't
ty more storage space to keep the mold
and analyze them all so that all goes on
in a kind of office block full of
computers just next door to the Atlas
experiment and then it gets farmed out
around the world in on a kind of cloud
gridded firm computers big data sensors
as one in Chicago and one in Brookhaven
I think like in the u.s. we have one in
altitude in the UK all the major
collaborators have them so that gets
spread around and then again in the end
hands upon our laptops and we do physics
within that's her works so that's the
sort of infrastructure you need in order
to do this science so dinner overview
for and I told you why if you want high
energy it has to be so big but I haven't
told you is why high energies it's all
interesting what's the point why he
returned all this I know there are
several ways people like to answer that
question you hear it called the Big Bang
machine and say we're studying the
physics of the early universe and
there's an element of truth in that I
can answer questions that probably
afterwards if you like but the way I
like to think of it is what we're doing
is actually we're studying the structure
of matter of nature around us not so
we're not looking at the nation the
early universe we're looking at what's
happening now one of the things around
was made of now with the highest
resolution we can and in that context
you can sort of think that the LHC is a
is a big microscope and I'm going to
demonstrate this with a absolutely super
high-tech demonstration which is
actually just a ripple tank may of lyman
in bonn maybe this video so you've got
to imagine you're going to see ripples
waves in the water you've got to imagine
the waves that are being the protons
unless they're probing another proton
okay and this is the Atlas detector this
is a beam of protons and someone's going
to put a blob in there which you got to
imagine is something that's inside the
other proton so they put this blob in
and the artless would tell them that
blobs there because the waves are
distorted here you could analyze the
pattern of waves on the screen here and
you could definitely tell the blob was
there you could probably tell I big it
was roughly maybe even something about
its shape if you did a really good job
now dip on other blog
and you is completely invisible the
waves of reformed by the time they get
to the screen you does you don't see it
at all which all you're doing is looking
at the way so you don't see it now what
happens crank up the energy the
frequency goes up the wavelength goes
down now you could see it you can down
tell the blog was there by detecting the
pattern of waves on the screen in and
that's really that's what we're doing is
a very deep correlation with in physics
in which this is sort of faithful
analogy that if you want if you go to
higher energy than what you're doing is
going too fast the vibrations and that
means growing shorter wavelength if you
want to see something then you need a
wavelength at least as small as the
thing you want to see so for instance if
our eyes were sensitive to radar then we
would there would be great for seeing
ships and planes but I wouldn't be able
to see you because the wavelength of
radar is a couple of meters or something
whereas you and your smaller than that
so the waves would reform I would never
see where a darwaze scattered off of you
optical lights finest few hundred
nanometers pretty good for seeing small
things but if you want to see even
smaller than that then you need to go to
x rays which are higher energy photons
or electrons or in the end something
like the LA to see and what we're really
doing with retirement ease is we have
the shortest wavelength microscope if
you like for seeing the structure of
matter and we're looking and we're not
just inside the assume we're looking
inside the Tomic nucleus in fact we're
looking inside a proton and inside the
proce on our courts which as far as we
know a fundamental but that as far as we
know is really important because as far
as we know just means how closely we
looked as far as we know there's nothing
inside electrons and there's nothing he
said works but that that means how good
is your microscope it's a statement
experimental e is only true as far as
you've been able to look and the LHC is
looking more closely than anyone's ever
managed a lot before what I've got on
the screen here is a result of that if
not just a yellow tseebo of all the
experiments have gone before all the
working system probing the structure of
matter these are the kind of the axes in
the Standard Model of particle physics
which is our best theory for what's
going on and in that theory all these
things really are fundamental that
infinitely small particles that are not
made of anything else the claim is that
everything in universe
is made up of quartz here leptons here
and then the forces between them what
you see on the screen is the whole story
everything's made of that and this stuff
is not made of anything else okay that's
the theory now that's only true insofar
as we managed to do the experiments to
validate it but it's definitely
describes a huge amount of data are very
very accurately what you see here is
open the down quark which is what make
up protons and neutrons you see it which
are in every nucleus every atomic
nucleus you've got electrons here and
then there's this neutrino that goes
with them with neutrinos are not really
the topic of this talk but there's a lot
of them in this room in the moment they
come from the Sun and they hardly
interact with anything and then you see
the whole thing is copied again as a
charm quark and a strange call here and
the muon that with the particles that i
showed you before the heavier version of
the electron and it has a neutrino to
the top quark from the bottom quark and
an even heavier left on which is what
Sarah students were working on when I
was stunned the model Paulina under and
the lepton that goes with that we don't
really know why it's coffee three times
but it is everyone gets heavier and we
know there are no more of them at least
there are no more they look the same
dimension slightly modified ones but
there's nothing else with a light
neutrino princess and then they they
interact by the photon which is what's
coming out of here you're seeing me with
is the carrier of the electromagnetism
and it's also light electromagnetic
waves the blue one which is what sticks
the porks inside the protons and
neutrons and then the double you know
Zed which carried a weak force which is
is really short distance so you have to
see in everyday life is set to some
radioactivity case it's the only force
the neutrinos experience and it's
crucial for instance in making the Sun
work but it's buried inside the nucleus
the range is socially you don't see it a
mess you got to really hiring the
exponents and that's it or not quiet
because there's something going on in
the background there and there's a very
difficult and easy question to ask
difficult questions to answer which
naturally I've asked them me when I've
given this talk in primary schools so
like a ten-year-old child ask me the
questions and I can something that is
infinitely small and not made of
anything else how can I even be anything
how can it why anything I can do
anything
and that's a very deep question which
actually was exercising the minds of
theorists even before we'd heard of
court even before we knew that quartz
were real or anything in the early 60s
because it turns out as well as being a
kind of conceptually difficult question
to get your head round that is also
mathematically very difficult question
to answer in any kind of coherent theory
the theories we have that guide these
forces are based on symmetry principles
and it turns out that mass of the mass
of an infinitely of a fundamental
particle can actually destroy those
symmetries and therefore this ploy to
old theory and that was a very unknown
problem even before we had the theory it
was like yeah but when you put this
theory together you'll still you'll have
this huge problem when people trying to
put together the theory even when they
thought that had runners were with
fundamental particles they thought it
was a problem with them and then they
found out oh no they're made of cork so
that's ok cuz you can have mass if it's
made of something else the masses to do
with the binding energy of the things
and that's all ok but if it's not made
of anything else that God doesn't work
and you're left with a problem and to
Belgium physicists called the Francois
Englert Robert Brout came up with a way
roundness that works mathematically and
a couple of weeks they are in parallel
really publishing a couple of weeks
later peter higgs in edinburgh came up
with the same idea and what he did was
he filled the whole universe with with a
new energy field a quantum energy field
and the mass of these particles actually
becomes something they get by sticking
to this field rather than something i
have internally it's something i gave i
stick into this field and that worked it
made on the mass work and everything and
that's of course this thing you might
wonder since i said that angular and
brad did it first why it's got a big H
on it and why it's called Higgs and the
reason for that is arguably a little
unfair but it's true is that Peter Higgs
paper had a was a bit more explicit
about how you might detect this field so
I don't I mean it as a theorist maybe
just inventing this whole field and
making the theory hang together is
satisfying as an experimentalist I'd
like a bit of evidence that what you've
just done I think it's quite a bold
steps with inventing the energy field
that fills the whole universe in
and just to make mask on i right so how
would you discover it it's rather
difficult to discover to prove that this
field is there to find evidence for it
because you can't like take one bit of
the universe without a field then
another with the field and compare them
because if it's anywhere it's everywhere
so that doesn't work and it turns out
the way to do it was implicit in an
equation I was implicit in all their
work but it was more explicit in Peter
Higgs each paper is you actually hit
that field really hard with something
and you make a ripple in it effectively
it's a quantum excitation but it's
essentially a ripple it's equivalent of
how do you know that there's air in this
hall okay there are many ways I'm tax of
knowing one's own this whole but if
there were if there were no air if there
was a vacuum in this hall then not only
would you not be paying attention you
wouldn't be able to hear me even if you
were paying attention because there'd be
no way for the information to get from
my mouth to your ears you would be under
reasons doing eyes obviously sound waves
what they are you can think of as being
an atmospheric filled in the hole what
I'm doing when I speak is I'm exciting
little ripples in that and they
transmitted through there the air and
they hit your ears and you detect them
that's an out good analogy for what we
can do at the I don't see with this
background field of the universe it
basically hits it really hard make a
ripple in it and that ripple is a
quantum excitation so actually looks
like a particle and that particle is the
Higgs boson so that's why we were so
excited to find it it's not like we've
got a stamp album with a gap and we need
a new particle to go in the gap is
between this is the evidence of this
mathematical idea and this whole energy
fields and fields of universities have
to be right it makes a very unique
prediction that if you hit it hard
enough then you should see this new
particle and it predicts what the new
particle should look like it doesn't
actually predict how hard you have to
hit the field or not exactly it we knew
enough to know the LHC will be able to
do it if it was right it was a
falsifiable theory in that sense but he
didn't it's exactly how hard but he did
say what if you made it this is what it
should look like and that's what what we
kind of did and i'm going to show you
the data for that now
I'm just going to skip over these
because that's not needed what time is
it clock stopped so what do we do in
order to discover a new particle at the
ifc what we do is we all we can do right
is look at the pieces when we smash
these protons together it's a fairly
crude for all our technology and grand
theories is fairly crude approach dreams
smash things together look at bits but
you get predictions of what these bits
are so if you make one of these Higgs
bosons well we have a theory that
predicted the existence of it also
predicts what will happen to it once
it's been made it doesn't travel very
far unlike the sound waves in the
auditorium here it doesn't travel very
phones right when I say doesn't travel
very far I mean 10 to the minus 20
something for a second is how long it
lives so it doesn't have time to get
anywhere really but but it decays into
other particles and those particles we
can see and we have a prediction for
what how they'll appear in the detector
they'll hit our the texture and we can
measure them so one of the things that
that it will decay to is a pair of
photons which is just lights just what
you're seeing me we've Mabel very
high-energy light much higher than
optical like the same stuff basically
and what you see here is a pair of those
photons these yellow blobs actually
registering the detector to very very
high energy photons and you can make a
hypothesis you can say well there's
there's lots of different ways actually
you can make a pair of photons how do I
know these came from a Higgs boson well
I don't actually there's no way of
telling you didn't individually whether
they did or not but I can count them and
look and what i can do is make a
hypothesis i can say well let's pretend
these photons came from a new particle
that i just made one i just made up even
if you do is then what would its massive
in and because we measured their energy
and angle and everything we can do a bit
of do a bit of relativistic calculus
kinematics this is casually you can
actually can actually do the sums are
not how hard you can add them add them
back together and you can work out what
the mass would have been if they come
from a new particle will give the decay
and you can just plot that you can count
them you can say for every pair of
photons that just can the masses
calculate an ass
put them on a histogram and wait to see
what happens and that's what's going on
here see that this is two years of our
lives going past here 2011-12 what
you're looking at here is is just what I
said so all the pairs of photons that we
see in the LHC with these high energies
what's the mass of the particle that
might have produced and if it really was
a particle to produce them and you can
see there's lots of different ways of
doing it but you can see that there's a
little concentration here and that's
what you expect if in all the possible
ways of making these two particles they
can leave it running it along again I
like watching this I started given I've
watched this you don't want to know how
many times it works it's the you see
that that we were kind of rolling the
dice for me when we crash these protons
together it's a quantum mechanical
process you don't get the same result
every time you get a distribution of
probabilities you can see that there are
a lot of photon pairs just in a smooth
distribution they're just made in all
kinds of different random ways and to
find a little bump like this which is
actually a 125 roughly 125 times the
mass of the proton in fact you see it's
not there was all kinds of excitement
about a bomb ban here at some point and
you know and it goes away see the error
bars are reflecting the statistical
uncertainty and you need to roll the
dice more and more times this is why we
sell we need more data we need more data
what that's doing is shrinking those
Arab as down and almost of those bumps
go away with one of them doesn't and
that's what happens we announced this in
2012 and July default actually on 21
2012 and July the third I was in CERN
watched Fabiola Gianotti who's ahead of
our experiment then is now director
general concern in fact kind of give the
presentation that she was the practice
presentation for what she was going to
say to the world the day after about the
discovery it was really the first time
we'd actually seen all our data put
together in one place and it was quite
amazing quite an emotional experience
and I thought yes we've really got a
beef and eggs and I know before nearly
anyone else about the other three days
of people on Allison another 3,000 our
CMS and Rolf Heuer you probably miss
director general reserve but I went then
I had to go back to London because I was
head of the UK
about this and not all the journalists
could afford to go to Geneva and the
politicians didn't go to Geneva so but
the science minister wanted people there
and we had a little press conference in
the event and a lot of UK science has
turned up all much the webcast of the
hotels and everything which was I'd
rather have been in Geneva frankly but
it was a good thing anyway and I hadn't
seen the results from CMS which is the
rival experiment I knew that had
something obviously the rumors flying
around but actually seeing really what
they were was really important and Jim
Bertie who was is the the UK head of CMS
at the time it was also actually a
spokesperson of CMS for what a long
while was doing the equivalent job that
I was doing for Alice he was doing it
for the rival experiment and we got out
at five o'clock in the morning we were
going to be on the radio at six o'clock
in the morning we knew we were going to
miss the presentations and we were
desperate to see them he really wanted
to see alice and i want to see the CMS
and we hadn't been able to get them
because it only been finished a night
before so we don't know what was going
on so there's this moment when we sat
down at half-past five in the morning in
this big hole in Westminster in London
and he showed me the CMS results and I
showed it in the Atlas Resource and what
surprised me was I got a real kind of
thumb to the gut I real I thought I
believed that was open till but I only
really believe it when I saw this which
is to CMS are the same thing it's adding
tells you something really important
about science that you you you do the
best you can not to fool yourself as
founder who today but but it's only when
someone else with a completely different
set of people set of politics
statistically independent data sample
and completely different detector
technology comes up with the same result
then you realize you've really learned
something about nature and not just
about your own you know fantasy about
what was going on oh this is really
avoid the same same book in the same
place I mean I should have known because
we also had all the bumps this is a this
is to muons of three electrons which
also is another way the Higgs can be K
and you see their black points of the
data collecting the red histogram is
what life would be like if there was no
Higgs and you see there's a point here
where the data diverges we got excited
by this for a while at one point that
you see here is it growing you see a
knowledge fundamental not new knowledge
about the universe kind of
growing out of this background chaos of
statistical error which i think is still
rather beautiful and if you zoom in on
it which we will do in a minute and you
put in a model of a Higgs boson it
roughly gets it right that's we know
better than we can get it more writing
than that now but it's telling me
something CMS actually did one where
same plots is the same distribution but
now for CMS where the answers in already
this is what a Higgs would look like and
again watching the Arab a shrink is more
and more data come and seeing that the
data follow the register gram you know
with pauses and glitches and things that
you get excited about and then
disappointed about and then but in the
end you see that it works out and that
bomb though all of those bumps were in
the same place which tells you they're
all the same particle decay became
different ways in different d-texas for
the same thing we have much much more
other evidence for that now and when
you're studying it the probabilities
match up to being the particle that was
predicted in the 60s that was the that
is the ripple in this background field
of the universe and the background field
of the universe is what gives
fundamental particles mass so now in
principle our theory just works and we
can all go home and do something that
dance or something is that look at the
dance is well maybe there's a lot more
to it than that I'm not going to spend
very long on it but i just want don't
want to leave you with the idea of
physics is it kind of done and dusted
aren't we clever itself finished kind of
deal because it's definitely not true
there's a lot more you want to learn
about the Higgs even where I'm not going
to go through all this don't worry but
even whether there might be more of them
I don't know why this big one looks so
worried that there might be more Higgs
bosons or various things showing up at
the moment that might be hints of that I
also sort of lied when I said that all
the universe is made of this and this is
made of nothing else in the theory this
is fundamental and in the standard model
this is all there is but we have very
good apps for physical evidence that
there's this stuff got that matter out
there that we actually the majority of
mass in the universe and we don't really
understand what it is there isn't an
obvious candidate in the standard model
for it what I'm showing you here is
actually I'm head of physics and
astronomy at UCL and the astrophysicists
always have to go one better so we have
the biggest physics experiment in the
world
they do collisions with with galaxy
clusters like so can't be that really
these are these images of galaxies oh
staff Buster's colliding with each other
and you can look in the optical and you
see the stars passing by each other
you're looking infrared and you see the
gas in the galaxy heating up and you can
see that the emissions of that heating
up and the gas kind of collides some
heat up whereas the stars passed by
because they're not very very sparse and
the question is what if these things are
actually 75% doubt and that's where does
that go does it bang into itself or does
it just pass through and we can is dark
so we transparent actually as Lisa
Rendell's trying to rename it as
transparent and she's right really it's
not that it's transparent but the the
you can tell it's there only from his
gravitational interactions but we could
use the way it bends light around it to
actually map it out to some extent and
they've seen from these that the dark
matter is is more following the stars
than following the gas so it tells you
that that matter actually doesn't
interact very much with itself either
which is something we didn't know a
little while ago I find it tremendously
exciting that the astrophysicists are
managing to learn things about the
properties of that massive in this kind
of way but it really makes me annoyed
and we really should actually make more
of it at the LHC and we might make more
event at the LHC in the lab and really
work out what's going on there but it's
certainly a big gap in the theory
certainly big unanswered physics
questions to what most of the mass of
the universe actually is and finally
just for now there are other questions
as well I won't go through but we also
don't really understand why the
universe's is made almost entirely these
seams of matter because in the Big Bang
than you know and in the LHC collisions
we make matter and antimatter in equal
not equal equal amounts and of course
when it makes it annihilate which is
what the artist is trying to illustrate
here if you meet an antimatter person do
not check their hand but we don't this
isn't clearly not happening in the
universe around so we don't know where
all the antimatter went and then the
theory doesn't really accommodate it
very well so actually the LHC the
experiment that's one of the many things
even specialized in studying but there
are other other ways of looking at see
their experiments in Chicago Fermilab
looking for evidence of why this
happened and we may learn something
about it from Atlas and CMS as well so
that was a just a quick whistle stop I
show you the bombs are important this is
a book we don't understand yet it may
just be one of those that goes away in
the date sense is much higher energy
than the previous one sixty thousand
times mass of the proton we don't know
we're watching it carefully we add
another one in the pairs of photons
which is the same distribution we found
the Higgs in at lower masses we have
another bump here is that a real bug
poison part of that statistical noise we
don't yet know it's on the face of it it
looks quite real but then we're looking
at a lot of different things there will
be some fake boobs and we have to just
get some more data and look so it's
still a very exciting time it's been a
fairly wonderful times of your
physicists of us use is still a lot of
excitement in the future I've her
disappear just to show that we do have
ridiculous dreams this is allowed
chadron collide are looking quite small
compared to what might be next if we can
if we think is the point to it and
justification that's a view of it from
the juror but it's not all just bigger
is better e that this is an accelerator
chip design and Stanford where you can
actually get a higher acceleration
gradient in that chip that's a human
finger if it's on in that chip than you
can in one of the cavities of the
concern the snag slight snag is that you
have to fire absolutely enormous laser
through transversely and then you'll get
the electrons going that way but if you
can find out a way to do that then then
you could build something of the
energies certain in a few hundred meters
rather than 27 kilometers so I show that
not because I think that's what we're
going to do it something that's useful
but maybe for low energy things but we
were also there are many other
innovative ways of the developing of
processing the data detecting the
particles getting the particles up to
high energy and that's going on all the
time as well so it's not just a matter
of building bigger tunnels but we have
plenty of interesting physics questions
to address and lots of interesting
technology options to to address them as
well I think so I should leave you with
that thought
you got more questions anyone you've got
questions in your friction sure yep ah
I'm the only the honest answer is I
don't know exactly but it's it's the
output of a fairly major substation so I
don't know the number in gigawatts or
anything but not the not as much as a
previous experiment that was there so
the previous experiment in the same
tunnel had synchrotron loss it was
losing energy it was an electron
collider and then they used after did
had to deal with the French powernet
grid and they were not allowed to run it
in the winter because of all the ski
lifts and heating that was running so it
was significant on the level of the
power usage of a city like to neither
it's in that case it's less than that
now actually because protons are not as
energy-hungry wants their Lots OMG and
there's a cryogenic system that keeps it
the superconducting magnets who don't
require as much input power there is
still very significant I don't know the
number i'm afraid
well everything's made of how does it
manifest itself it for instance so first
of all the electron is obviously a
funder that's something we've known
about for more than a hundred years and
that understanding how electrons
interact this is how we understand h2o
and chemistry at some level as well it's
about level of a sub structure of the
atom which is you know the nucleus and
the electron is an important thing to
understand from that point that is okay
right
yes know that while the electron is a
basic particles so here's a fundamental
particle and what the theory tells us in
that so it's a very good point actually
that it doesn't tell you the mass and
that's one of the questions I could have
added as an unknown thing so the Higgs
allows things to have mass but it
doesn't predict what the masses will be
and whether there's a pattern to the
masses so in the in the periodic table
there's a pattern to the properties in
the masses of the the elements that is
kind of reminiscent of the pattern that
we have of the fundamental particles but
there's no reason for it in our model
whereas in the periodic table we
understand it in terms of the
subscription of the elements so that's
an open question the courts is a bit
different so understanding the hadrons
are made of quartz really does tell you
their properties so you can work out
their masses can be calculated using
lattice techniques and spin and their
charge and all those properties are
derived from the fact that they're made
of course so in that case it does begin
the argument made for building this
enormous thing is that it tells us a lot
about the world you tell me that the
world is made of those quacks yes have
them what did you mean when you say that
the world is made of it how does that
tell me anything about this world um it
tells you it's including the bigs yes it
sort of was nobody was including the
bigs now yes it's I'm not sure it does I
mean the idea that there are there are
fundamental principles and there are
fundamental particles okay so the
fundamental principle of things like
symmetry breaking for instance that the
Higgs mechanism was developed in in unit
version of it was developed in condensed
matter physics and you see the same
emergent principles that we're seeing
and what we think the fundamental
particles play a role in things like the
properties of materials and stuff so
there's a really deep connection there
between how long there are questions
being raised by condensed matter
physicists as to whether the breaking of
symmetry came from there well white or
how is it helped in condensed matter
when you talk about things to know that
there's broken symmetry it in particle
physics well I think I would draw the
distinction between the frontiers of
knowledge ok so I think there's a valid
frontier of knowledge which is what are
things made of if you look at them the
shortest distances we can access which
is what we're doing there are also
fundamental principles which are equally
fundamentally so fundamental can be used
to say that as a particle is not made of
anything but I think something like
spontaneous symmetry breaking for
instance is a fundamental principle that
is manifested in nature on many
different scales and i think that
there's a relationship but in both
directions and i think you there's a
kind of frontier of complexity and
emergent principles there's a frontier
of the kind of reductionist frontier of
what things actually made of when if you
look closely enough how they really
inform each other is I think via these
principles that emerge like symmetry
breaking stuff where you see
that there are the behaviors in
condensed matter physics and if we
didn't know that electrons were
fundamental at least to some energy
scale we would not make sense there are
other ones that really don't care about
that actually and that what we're
learning at the LHC is completely
irrelevant for because that the
principle that the physics you're seeing
is emerged is a much lower energy scale
in a complex system so i think it's i
wouldn't claim this is the ultimate the
ultimat not i'm not a fan of kind of
theories of everything which says if you
write down an equation of something you
understand the whole world that's to
meet transparently nonsense on the other
hand it is valuable to know the Dirac
equation is of use to people trying to
understand the electrons and stand the
model is of use to people wanting to
understand the way electrons and atoms
and things interact Hey thank you yep
the Higgs field me the console
only a philosopher fatality
yep
so actually following on from the
previous question what it's told us is
that we've got principle of spontaneous
symmetry breaking underlies that field
right and that's what predicts the Higgs
boson in a way you could if you're not a
fan of if you if you actually don't care
what the fundamental constituents of
nature are the fact that that symmetry
principle has made a prediction of the
scalar boson which is what we've seen is
a really deep it tells you to some
reality in that maths there's tells you
that nature really does care about that
mathematical principle in a way that is
actually really mysterious right there's
no reason it should but that that was
done purely sweet maths and predicted
and a predictor something we can see and
reproduce it in an experiment like ours
to me is entirely wonderful and it
actually I go back to visa I don't
really care whether the standard model
is is the the inner layer of the onion
or whether there's more to find that I'm
fascinated by the whole process but it's
really something startling that even if
the Higgs is not a fundamental particle
even if corks and gluten electrons turn
out to actually have some internal
structure at this scale of nature that
symmetry that mathematical symmetry
principle that was invoked to make the
theory work made a prediction that he's
actually realized physically that is
really wonderful to me and will stand
whatever whether the standard model
turns out to be another low-energy
effective theory or not that will stand
that that prediction works that must
have some reality in real physical
nation that's stunning more questions
thank you very much